oui merci merci madame la Présidente sur
la partie 44 bis
quel aveu de faiblesse quel aveu de
faiblesse ouais ouais franchement
je crois que franchement je l'ai dit
beaucoup de fois ces derniers temps mais
là un terrible aveu de à votre faiblesse
oui votre majorité se fissure ce texte
n'a pas été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
et on a vu on a vu les conditions
l'ensemble des syndicats Unis demandent
demande solennellement être reçue par le
Président de la République qui leur
refuse toujours d'ouvrir la porte et de
et de continuer des discussions
l'ensemble de la population est dans la
rue et attend une réponse et vous voulez
passer en force quelle image vous donnez
c'est d'une brutalité c'est une
aliénation du Parlement c'est tout
simplement honteux honteux
Victor Hugo avait appelé son chien Sénat
et oui le Sénat est devenu le toutou du
gouvernement voilà où on en est voilà où
on en est
alors
la majorité sénatoriale effectivement
voilà oui allez allez oui monsieur
carucci je sais que ça vous embête mais
je continuerai je continuerai voilà oui
rappelle aux règlements oui on a pas le
droit de s'adresser quand je parle voilà
ok voilà
donc moi je demande également évidemment
évidemment une suspension de séance et
les suspension de séance qui soit
suffisantes parce que vous vous accordez
une suspension de séance le gouvernement
s'accorde une suspension de séance pour
pouvoir réécrire son texte on a quand
même la possibilité de pouvoir réagir et
pouvoir se réunir mais en tout cas moi
je le dis on ne pourra pas continuer à
accepter cette allégation du du
Parlement et on nous on ne sera pas le
toutou du gouvernement
[Musique]